[Music]
it's not bigger you're absolutely right
but sometimes we have to do what is best
for everyone not what is fair I would
hope that we finally get some of the
women standing up for their rights in
season two but how are you gonna be
incorporated into that what is your
dynamic with Elizabeth well we're gonna
see a difference yes you know they do to
me have you seen this the imagination
people to show you know they do to me if
I told you two months this is really I
want to keep both my thumbs
it could be children or else I'd die
[Music]
Lizabeth also said in another interview
that this season 2 was going to be
insane was it sir movie what can you
tease from season 2 in a few words well
the thing I'm most excited about is at
the end of season 1 spoiler alert is you
know you see Samara Wiley's character
meet up with mine in Canada and so
there's lots of exciting things which
might be revealed about the world
outside of Gilead right go with mommy
it's alright for me that she that
relationship between my character Luke
and Elizabeth mosses is really like I
guess if it means central to the show
just because you get to see what life
was like before Gilead you get to see
what that relationship was like and and
how you can be in a normal situation and
that kind of descends into the kind of
chaos that happens in Gilead then a lot
of people come up to me and said you
know how watching the show they really
fear that something like that might
happen some really big news for Hulu a
historic win you guys just won two TCA
awards yeah
what was your reaction I mean we were
delighted it's been amazing really to be
part of the show which is taken so well
in you know popular culture and people
responding to it so to have the critics
as well say give us that big thumbs up
you know I think it meant a lot to us so
she's alive
we believe so yes
[Music]
how difficult is it for you to do your
American accent and do you use a coach
you know so it took me I'm not like
someone who's very good at accents like
it's not something that comes next but
like there's some people who just like
bang out accents and I had to work so
hard for my American accent when I first
came here to America you know I would
spend days in my American accent to try
and perfective Will Smith was someone I
studied I was just studied John let John
Legend know John Legend yeah brain fart
and then now I studied Quentin Tarantino
and I studied yeah so I just studied
different people just to kind of like
really gonna learn how they speak who is
the most fun on set
I mean both Samira and Elizabeth are
really fun to hang out with they got a
wicked sense of humor but I I love
hanging out with Elizabeth just because
you know she's got quite a dark cheeky
sense of humor and it kind of matches
with the British Sensibility a lot